you
okay let's have some fun here we have
another 30-minute bullet tournament
one-minute chess Kovac opponent number
uno the caro-kann who plays the Carol
Kannan bullet Kovac all right I I do too
all right let's just go in for this
okay not the most testing line in the
world is it I'm going to try to mate
them on h7 if you castles
hmm all right let's demote one of the
pieces that night's going to be a bit of
a bug look a challenge um but you know
what he's going nowhere he's going to
reinforce with b5 so he's got to go
that's a good way to drop upon hmm g3
kingi - well the night ok let's let's go
here well you're not giving me what I
want I'm going to get a queen trade now
I can't afford that not playing this
very well got to go all in here try to
put some dent in the king side it's held
together by a thread what I have all
right need to babysit there my knight
needs to play to g5 Queen h6 now Queen
h5 Queen here defends all but at least I
skip up a pawn that's nice
timely Knight g5 hmm I'm there just in
time to defend this move should be
winning just put a clamp down on
everything improve the King get these
pawns marching get them all involved
right clock situation is not good that's
helpful just get rid of that pond oh you
sneaky guy you get over here we being
sneaky again what's with the sneakiness
Bishop c5 who plays Bishop c5 sneaked
artists being sneaky
ah okay it's a good try though it's
definitely good try
definitely a good try all righty let's
put a clamp down on b4 reinforce that
guy my Knights gone for a little dance
pick up the bond we have a little pin
action offer some trades Discovery's
counterpunch c5 Bishop here the Knights
free I want to get rid of them
let's take with the Queen now I've
connected past pawn let's throw another
pin in there and I don't know we're
going to try to rattle the Queen
position soon like this night before get
rid of that block hater can also
consider taking that rook I do it on the
next move and let's get pushing here
Pass pawn open his eyes let's just
address this Knight position yeah
no rush here no rush a lot another check
be thrown in now I'm throwing a punch at
the knight offer Queen exchange for
starters
keep pushing get rid of the bishop
dropping the pawn with that move though
I guess we'll go here I want to get rid
of that night I could take him out and
promote have this Square covered she
tries to get active nope
they missed I was on the Queen back to
tournament land we are and you'll notice
that that first win is 4 points what's
the term they used to describe that hmm
I forget what term is used but yeah they
just did it we're all a rocket start
that's the term that was used you win
that first game it's considered a rocket
start
okay to take some care over that pond
Queen c7 I have Knight b5 also Bishop f4
maybe I want a Castle queenside I'm
going to go for that caveman g4 g5 rip
open the H file G file you know what I
meant
no oh I didn't move let's keep going if
he's still around
we have tricky stuff like this Queen h5
and h7 how are they stopping this mate
one two three the rook moves I think
we're having exactly that that's mate
back to tournament a thorn and a half is
that pawn on g6 as one of those
clearance moves I just wanted my f3
Knight out of the way okay 33 players in
this one I have 12 few others had a win
Game one so they had a rocket start as
well
stride Sicilian okay
I don't play d6 as much as E six and
bullet but let's give this a try what do
we call this dragon dragon Dorf okay and
okay they're coming after me yep let's
kick him away is he going to go anywhere
though okay they're removing my bishop
trying to kill me here let's put an end
to that I'm gonna play rook h8 I think
h4b four would have been better
H four before the bishop exchange
because this allows you to kind of keep
things closed over here I'm relying
heavily on my control over the h5 pond
this is not working because I had the
night here as well otherwise there would
have been a nice fork throwing a punch
at the bishop I think I should just
crack open the position here
eirick has some lateral movement Queen
a5 is right around the corner let's do
this I'd like to feel that my king is
under some heat he's unprotected have
the Queen's off and now I'm threatening
the rook potentially trying to take
advantage of this pin I could do that
right now who I'm giving up this square
they're really really down on time now a
spawn my rook is ideally placed right
behind him that's a good move and they
have to blitz it out dropping everything
now I don't have any time
back to tournament I don't think I
played that well as mentioned if they
start with first h4 before exchanging on
g7 I'm not able to get that h5 move in
h4 first Bishop takes Bishop I recapture
and then h5 and then it's a totally
different ballgame
all right let's see what we could do all
right let's clamp down on d6 maybe jump
into d6 let's try that let's open this
up right away
Waunakee in on this hole and recapture
with the piece I want to get my bishop
here if I get my bishop here it's almost
yeah I think it's already a win now just
because of this grip over the dark
squares and I want to stop knight here
it's committal move yeah they were in
pre-move mode Bishop's presence isn't
felt I'm never moving my Bishop rook g1
and then looking for made on the G file
just keep everything coordinated
over here just want to make sure that
that Bishop doesn't get active I guess
he could go here let's stop that
altogether in fact he's being picked up
now no save squares for that guy he
resigned back to tournament twenty is
where we're at Zann bottle right out of
my heels one game away 20 minutes 42
seconds I am blessed let's try another
Sicilian let's try you six this time get
the fishing pole stuff out of my system
Who am I kidding it's not going to go
away now they're going to go queenside I
guess but with this move here helps me
to open up some stuff the B and C files
I'll insert that first and I think this
buys me some time now to break in the
center they can't recapture with this
book this guy chopping the rook not--but
oh there is a bishop move with check
okay I'll let them do it if they want
I'll get the a file if they do that so
they could get the material back okay
they're not going for that could take
here my queen is really really active
Bishop d2 and its mate Bishop is under
fire the bishop goes here I could give a
check and then pick up the night the
King would obstruct the Queen probably
just pick up the Queen is that good
enough
no let's actually check and then this is
going to be me let's miss that idea till
the last second did I realize I had that
move Bishop a three sharp a three twenty
four twenty fourteen thirty five players
in this one okay let's see who we get
now pehoe vaq again the sneaky player
from our round one encounter Queens
gambit declined okay let's hunt down
that light square Bishop let's continue
to develop I want to take that Bishop
just yet oh is this Grandmaster draw
Grandmaster drunk
now we take them challenge that night in
your position strike at that pond open
the position up you got the bishops oh I
thought we were going to have a Grand
Master draw a Grand Master Chao look at
this lining up H to tak Tico's
see five how much better is he gonna get
no no no no no maybe he's going to be
helped I can't wait for him to be helped
coming over here to bring the pain or at
least try to get rid of him he's no good
this could open up at any moment
go ahead shut it down now any files
opened up let's can test it immediately
Queens restricted she can't feel too
good let's get a flight square in here
Queen f2a Queen g3 dark Square
weaknesses slithering in oh it's
opposite color Bishop's I don't even
realize that I'm going to need a g4
break I think mmm I take there there's a
discovery now preparing this I'll still
do it oh that's a check oh it's more
than check that's mate back to
tournament 28 24 16 17 and change Wow
yeah I was thinking for some reason we
had the same color bishops yeah I have
to uh
look a little closer next time
Alekhine's defense let's throw the four
pawns at black now I like this is good
enough and yeah because I haven't play
along the F file I have some space
ah okay I'm going to let them fork me if
they want still available I feel like I
would still have some attack okay
they're not going for that forcing a
serious weakness now dark square
weakness I want to get rid of their dark
square bishop throw a knight on f6 and
look for me a queen on h6 a knight on f6
some combination of the whoa you're
going to want to get out of that I don't
know where to go
oh my god find some square I guess here
I guess here okay to defend d4 don't get
made it on g2 okay that Queen is a giant
pest look at this another sneak artist
that's my night to move okay now we're
crashing through here taking advantage
of a pin
he's not playing h-file let's give a
check I want to take stuff with check I
lied I want mate it made on h7 32:28 15
minutes and change Zen Bato I have not
been paired up with yet no of course I
haven't
we're both can't both be perfect here
he's in game right now I guess I'm not
getting paired 40 players are now in
this one Mathi joy is right there Lu foe
next opponent watch its throw and Lu foe
if we're going to move yes alrighty
let's try c5 yeah and I go for c5 now c4
Queen b3 oh is going to play C 4 let's
just preserve this and eventually I have
some tactics against the Queen like
right now looking to take a couple times
here let's grab some space
and I don't know if that was actually
necessary for me to drop my queen back
home
keep them here okay I want to get this
break in a five they don't want any of
it opposite their queen I'm looking for
b5 now I want to break open the Queen
side get these two guns working there we
go this is being undermined now I'm
opposite the king take once and I can
probably take again have this move break
that pin important important move there
night
here is a move and also I could take
this now this is working out I got
discovered checks which is better look
after the Queen
so check 15 seconds they resigned back
to Turner we are 36 32
oh we're going to get paired up at some
point and I wonder what the clock
situation is in this game I guess we
could have a quick peek it's still a
while to go on that one 30 seconds each
okay I am blessed again let's try let's
try for this okay let's break the pin
continue to develop castle II five on
board let's close down the center and
look to maybe do something against this
Knight Queen h4 is pretty active Bishop
g5 and how are they getting out of that
pin let's see
looking for d6 next h6 I can take 35
and I also considered this yeah let's do
this
that was a threat maybe to do that and
then Knight d5 yeah I probably should
have done that right away hmm
all right I'll take oh because I'm
getting this pawn in the end just seeing
that now okay I just want to take here
next and have my bishops eyes open up
Knight d5 as well strong rook is lost
Queen f8 I take the knight this is
collapsing get another piece first rook
here could do this deflect the Queen
away from the rook and just push through
discover check they resigned back
determined 40 this guy keeps matching me
I'm up for he's up for when are we going
to get paired I'm their chess
all right let's try a king-size pink
ghetto
okay I feel like this night is boxed out
very well now the bishop is soon to be
trapped no not quite
in between er strong piece that's a fork
let's save them I have a three covered
let's stop any more push probably
unnecessary I'm allowing some possible
tactics just like that I don't wanna
just want to get my rook over here
let's just drop back let's go here and
immediately challenge the Queen Queen h6
if the Queen trade is avoided this is
leading to mate back to tournament 4440
this guy keeps matching me okay ten
minutes 14 seconds see we get d4 let's
try g6 so kind of a flexible start here
break up the center get rid of that
Center pawn oh yeah I could do this I
have this square covered maybe I could
have captured there I'm not sure I don't
know why they gave up the dark square
bishop he's really really strong on c4
okay look for Queen improvement could
also go with the King improvement I'd
love to act fast in this position Knight
d3 could still move forward I'm throwing
a strike here I will pick him up no I
won't be dropping this with a fork
didn't see that move in between her yeah
so they damaged my structure but now I
have this skewer didn't see that this
was not calculated give a check first
defend with my king yeah this is too
much though they have to go into a pin
let's take here just want some trades
and we're going to have this guy control
these to stay coordinated improve the
King probably let's do this crack open
the dark squares for my King to enter
and play a role where's that going
to the bishop yeah that would have been
nice right let's capture that bishop
next time okay oh that's me okay back to
tournament 48:40 hit a speed bump who
knocked him out one
okay farmville team black
let's try Sicilian going for d4 I like
that idea
I'll go d5 I'm in a pin okay
Queen to e2 is good I guess they're
going to pile up there we're going to
have an ending where I'm down upon okay
try to strike at f2 really soon could be
interesting I have a development lead
that's about it though Knight g4 and
okay they have to go into a pin for
starters I want to stay on this diagonal
oh very nice very nice I think I get
that pawn they'll know I don't the
knight could enter and defend they miss
that let's improve the King improve the
King react
I guess we'll get that guy going come on
to secure my king position let's play h5
let's not drop upon um good move good
move good move I'm going to get that pun
Wow where's that night go flying no hmm
clock situation I want to keep a tricky
night around
whoo that must have been a mile slip it
must have been a mile slip I got to do
this I got to win this ending it me
nights they can't dodge all these checks
it's a good thing I didn't have to
demonstrate mate there it's do it just
was not going to happen can't force me
to Knights and a king versus a lone King
cannot force mate then 50 moves it's not
happening alright
Scandinavian town
not the most testing setup I'm throwing
it black alrighty let's just make some
natural moves rook on an open file get
all my pieces working alright ugly
structure incoming
all right I don't think they're in a
position to maintain the b5 pond
yikes
just drop some material not cool I push
that night around I think I could pick
that material back up though the a pond
is tough to defend is it not
give him a kick first I feel like there
isn't any rush worth taking that pond
and there I go I just take them now I
got the two bishops I have a flight
square here we go
forks rook there would have been good
huh there let's get pushing him now
let's improve the bishop first
interesting move already
hmm 19 seconds they have a time edge of
the night and I'm attacking c5 gotta get
this guy going huh yes now is the time
to do it some trades oh isn't he a
runner hmm seven seconds okay I know now
that wasn't the time to do that move hmm
three seconds let's see what kind of
magic I could pull off here Wow sneak
artist who's a sneak artist who's a
sneak artist who is a sneak artist oh my
god
point five I got it oh I can't talk
don't wait for me to talk I know it's
like a broken record don't wait for me
to talk oh I had a pull on the sneak
artist tactics just like pehoe vaq tried
in Game one
two minutes 33 seconds pinna ruski holy
cow my adrenaline is pumping here
oh my goodness
Chaz is a defense game you might be
tuned in for the first time you need to
understand that is an intense game oh
man there's no way I should have won
that one no way trying to get rid of my
dark square bishop why what's happening
why would I do that I don't have answers
give this a little check first here we
go
I'm doing this let's in it's upon sack
and I just want some rook activity and
in the end I have exactly that and I'm
going to rely upon this guy to restrict
these two okay I got this now not a win
just activity and soon to win the veep
on let's stop him cold if he's as soon
as he moves now big trouble I want to
get here with my king and allow that had
I got here there we go super active rook
wins upon and this is a one King and
pawn ending yeah I could do that hmm I
don't like I'm playing this okay this is
working I think the King could have
maybe tried to go over here a little
sooner
yeah he's going to push through King up
on
next no matter what they resigned back
to tournament well I got paired up again
maybe less than 40 now whose and Votto
had a tough streak there so it's drawn
now hmm under 30 yeah probably not going
to get paired I can't recall ever
getting paired with under 20 seconds
yeah not going to happen mmm Wow there
were some pretty wild games in there huh
oh my goodness very very tense some of
those games three seconds two one
confetti time top three myself Zen Votto
and farmville 43 in all let's have a
look at page two three four and five
already to the 42 of you took part this
good games all all right
you